[Music]
what's up guys we're here at e3 2018 my
name is Oscar Dez I'm joined by Ed Tran
hello and we have checked out
III s worst kept secret 103 was one of
the threes worst kept secrets it's just
cause for ya shock Edie
what is new about just calls for I
didn't play Just Cause 3 tell me all
right well if you like if you play Just
Cause 3 you probably know what to expect
them just cause 4 so it features the
same protagonist Rico Rodriguez on
another quest to liberate our region of
South America
solace solace and he's are going up
against the black hand mystery faction
once more but everything has been
improved and if you like sandbox stuff
and you like doing crazy creative stuff
with physics and just cause for looks a
little bit more of that so they've got a
new physics engine it's an upgraded
version of avalanches apex open-world
engine and the big new thing is that
they're simulating way more physics in
the world so that's in terms of weather
so there's wind now there are the one
big thing that they're pitching is like
huge disastrous weather effects to the
one that we that was shown to us was
like a huge tornado that was flying
through the land you could like send it
places and it would suck up 747s and
like completely destroyed bases in like
everything will be simulated in real
time so you can obviously use that to
your advantage as like win ramps or just
throw enemies into it and it's pretty
spectacular looking it could be a danger
as well right like we saw Rico getting
like dragged into the tornado from a
distance and the closer you are to the
tornado the the more powerful its
pulverized right
another thing is each vehicle has its
own aerodynamics now so we were chasing
the tornado in a storm chasers sort of
like a PC truck which was quite
resistant to the wind but obviously
other cars react to the wind differently
so new physics means new ways of
destruction and all the destruction
works a little differently so it just
goes through when you sort of talk down
instead of a chaos item it would just
explode in like one way but now that the
new engine and things if you shoot it in
different ways or destroyed in different
ways it will react in different ways so
you could say turn a huge explainable
chaos like gas tank to propel into the
and use that as a weapon rather than
just having it as a sort of point of
destruction the big part of just causes
obviously Rico's grappling hook and now
that's been expanded it's it's got a
greater depth in mod mod customization
so you can add behaviors to sort of each
of the sort of attachments or the
tethers so you can add sort of a pulse
effect to your retract you can add an
explosion you can make a make you can
trigger them by like holding the button
or pressing button it so it's all up to
you so one of the the new tether in Just
Cause 4 is a balloon thing so if you've
seen the Fulton balloon in Metal Gear
Solid 5 the phantom pain you know
exactly what this is exactly the same
brand and use it to your advantage so
you can say attach balloons to a
shipping container throat boosters on
the side of it and just activate the
boost and just ride a shipping container
like a Zeppelin which is a lot of fun
and though it seems like this time
around they're putting more of an
emphasis on the story of just causes all
right the past just cause the story
hasn't ever been that yeah it's always
been an over-the-top action game and
they've kind of lent into that in the
mechanics but yes they did acknowledge
that the story hasn't been great and
they're taking a more serious turn with
it and they're also trying to sort of
make the progression of the story more
fit in better with just causes open
world nature so they were saying it's a
nonlinear story there are lots of
components around the world where you
can do main missions and sort of add to
your progression be directed to them in
kind of order just wherever you go there
might be something for you to do you
don't need to like travel to a specific
point to progress and it seems like
there's more diversity in terms of the
world and the environments that you can
explore as well right yeah yeah that's
right they were showing us a rainforest
area which had a lot of hills and
mountains with verticality but they've
also said there are snowy areas deserts
all that kind of stuff it's a very
varied cool environment it's all one
consistent well so no sort of our
regions or sort of loading times in
between them so we see your point you
just go straight to it overall ads are
you looking forward to just close for
well I like messing around in my games
and I like doing stupid [ __ ] and so just
cause for the Just Cause series has
always been really great for that and
just calls for ads so many more systems
in sort of variables and factors to sort
of help with that sort of goofiness
so yeah all right like that kind of game
keep an eye on this one and for
everything else just calls for keep an
eye on gamespot calm
you